>> Jeff: THE ISLANDERS AND
THEIR TRAVELING WHITES, JACKETS
WEARIN
COULD NOT PLAY THE PUCK IN THIS
LOT.
THERE WAS ANDREW PEEKE.
PUCK TURNED OVER. IS 100TH NHL .
VARLAMOV COVERS UP.
WE WILL GET
ROSLOVIC, USING THAT SPEED, GETS
GOAL.
RIGHT THERE BROCK NELSON,
LEFT-HANDED CHART ON THE RIGHT
ACROSS THE LINE.
CENTERING BACK BEHIND THE
DEFENSE.
PAGEAU INTO THE SLOT, SHOT, A LF
HESITATION.
YOU'VE GOT GABRIEL CARLSRECTED,T
BACK TO BOQVIST.
SECONDS LEFT ON THE POWER PLAY..
DOBSON WITH A SHOT.
REBOUND.
UNABLE TO PULL
DON'T HOW THAT WENT IN
PICK IT UP, COMES OFFCE BY
ROBINSON.
A MERZLIKINS, LOOKS
PICKED UP BY BARZAL.GOT THIS
OF GOT PARISE ON
GOOD JOB BY ROSLOVIC,
ROSLOVIC COME ACROSS ICE, LESS
PASSING PURGING THE FIVE
MINUTE MARK.
A QUICK FEED COME ACROSS ICE,
LANDS RIGHT ON BJORKSTRAND'S
STICK.
GREAT JOB BY SILLINGER.
BOQVIST WILL DROP IT.
GOES OFF THE STICK OF WAHLSTROM,
.
SLASHING.
>> Jeff: VARLAMOV